hey if you'd like to support the
production of more move university video
tutorials then please visit the support
move section on move university comm
thank you and enjoy so now let's talk
about the regulation of cholesterol
synthesis we mentioned before what the
committed and rate limiting step of
cholesterol synthesis was and that was
the step that was catalyzed by HMG
co-reductase and we said that it was
highly regulated because it was both the
committed step as well as the rate
limiting step so it's highly regulated
and there are many different ways to
regulate its activity
as well as its availability so we'll
talk about that means just a second so
here is the step catalyzed by hmg-coa
reductase taking H of G ka and reducing
it to mevalonate which is of course the
molecule that was committed to
cholesterol synthesis so I want you to
consider this here so in the DNA we
would have the gene for the hmg-coa
reductase enzyme right because it's a
protein right so we would have a gene
for it okay and this gene for the
hmg-coa reductase can be transcribed
into an mRNA transcript and that
transcript can of course be translated
into the protein that is the actual
functional enzyme okay now that protein
of course can be degraded via
proteolysis to give just a bunch of free
amino acids okay now this enzyme here
can do its thing right that's that's
what we're really talking about we're
talking about this thing being able to
catalyze reactions that we just
mentioned now this enzyme can be
covalently modified via phosphorylation
to give the HIV co-heir reductase enzyme
with a phosphate group on it now all
these different things contribute to
what's going on with this enzyme now
aside from this part this arrow going
downwards here these first three arrows
up here
what is that call that's called the
central dogma and those those arrows
basically determine whether or not this
protein is even around right it has to
be transcribed and translated to even
make the protein and that has to it can
be pro realized so whether or not it's
even available is dependent upon these
first three up here okay these first
three situations how much of this gene
is being transcribed how much of it's
being translated and and whether or not
it's being protea lies or how often or
how much and so these three things
determine whether or not the protein is
even available right because if it's
pretty lies the it's just a bunch of
amino acids
and how quickly and how often it's
transcribed and translated to give us
this protein is important as well now
once we actually have this protein it
can be covalently modified right by
phosphorylation and that can alter the
activity of the enzyme okay so you
notice these LT s and this s T here the
L T stand for long term and s T stands
for short term so long term regulation
is going to focus on these three things
transcription of the gene translation of
the mRNA transcript and proteolysis of
the enzyme itself whereas covalent
modification occurs very short term
phosphorylation and dephosphorylation
can happen instead so that's a
short-term way of controlling the
activity of this enzyme whereas these
three are all ways of controlling
whether or not that that protein is even
around okay so I hope that intro was
helpful in kind of seeing this from an
overview perspective see in the next
videos thanks for watching thanks for
watching and be sure to LIKE comment
subscribe and share the video with
anyone you think might find it helpful
Thanks happy studying